Welcome back everybody to
the lecture 2
about types and classes.
In this part we're going to talk about
types of
functions and since we are dealing with
functional programming,
functions, values and types
are very important and since this
can be a little bit difficult for
beginners
please pay attention to this lecture in
particular because
if you miss this you will have
difficulties
in all the remaining lectures. I
will go a little bit slow here
and repeat many times because this is
super important
that you understand this part. What is a
function?
A function is a mapping from values
of one type to values of another type
Here are two
very simple examples of function types
the first one
is the function not (negation) which takes
a boolean
and returns another boolean.
Nothing too complicated.
Let's look at the second function here:
isDigit.
isDigit takes a character and checks
whether that character is a digit,
whether that character is 0, 1, ...
up to nine. The type of that is Char to Bool.
What that means is it takes a value in
the set of all characters
and will return a value in the set of
booleans.
In general a function from t1 to t2
is... The type t1 -> t2
is the type of functions that map values
from type t1 to values
of type t2. t1 is
also sometimes called the domain of the
function
and t2 is sometimes called the range
of the function.
Now you noticed that we write
the arrow of the function type is a nice
arrow,
but when you use the key board to
type in the actual code
you will type that as a dash followed by
a greater than sign,
We will use the nicer
syntax here but just you
be careful this is not how you
type in
actually the arrow. When you have a
function
just like with tuples and with lists
the types for the range and the domain
are
unrestricted. For example we can have
function here
add that takes as the argument a tuple
of two integers and returns as a result
another integer.
add of (x, y) equals x plus y.
You see here that
add takes a tuple of two integers
and returns a result that is an integer.
The other function here
is a function that takes an Int and
returns a list of integers.
That's perfectly fine and
the definition there: 0 to n returns
the list
[0..n] we have seen in the very
first lecture
that this square bracket with the
double dots denote the list from zero up
to n.
One thing,
if we make the types,
the arguments and the results of function types
arbitrary, they can be functions
themselves and this is where
curried functions come in. Instead of
defining add
to take a tuple of integers and return an
integer
in Haskell it is more common to define add
as follows:
we define add as a function that takes an
integer
and returns a function that takes
another integer
and returns an integer.
Look at this type here: add is a
function,
here we see that from this arrow,
that it takes an integer and returns a
function
that takes another integer and returns
an integer.
That is currying.
By itself currying is not
very complicated. Functions are just
values like lists an integers, there's
nothing special about this.
The thing where it becomes confusing is
that
in Haskell you don't have to write these
arrows here,
because this is so common,
the arrow associates to the right,
which means that you can write this
type as
Int -> Int -> Int and that's where it
becomes confusing for beginners.
You have to really know
when you read these types where to
put the parentheses.
For now there's nothing special here
add is a function that takes an integer
and returns another function that takes
an integer and then returns an integer.
Notice that both add
and add' return the same result,
but the normal add takes
a tuple so it
takes both arguments at the same time
whereas add' takes the arguments
one by one.
Functions that take their arguments one by
one are called
curried functions.
The person that invented
this way of dealing with functions,
where the functions take the arguments
one by one,
was Haskell B. Curry and Haskell
is named after him. That's where Haskell
comes from, just like Pascal
was named after Blaise Pascal,
Haskell is named after Haskell B. Curry,
the person that invented currying of
functions.
Every function that takes two arguments
can be turned into a function that takes
these arguments one by one.
For example here's a function mult that
takes three
parameters x, y and z and multiplies them.
mult x y z is x times y times z
One way to write this function would be
to take a tuple of
three values x, y and z and then
multiply them.
The Haskell way of doing this is to
take these arguments one by one:
mult x returns a function
that takes another argument y and then
its returns a function that takes
another argument z
and then when you have all these three
arguments, you can multiply them
to return the final Int.
So mult takes an integer,
returns a function mult x that takes
an integer y
that returns a new function mult x y
that takes an integer z
and returns the result x, y and z.
What we see here is that
in the type we still write the parentheses,
so the parentheses in the type
go left to right so the
function arrow
binds to the right but
when we write here mult x y
we don't put parentheses.
if we would put the parentheses there
we would write
(mult x) and then parentheses around that.
There the parentheses
associate to the left. For application
the parentheses associate to the left,
for the function arrow
they associate to the right and that
matches up perfectly,
so in practice we don't have to write any
parentheses.
Now you can ask yourself
why is this currying useful?
Why are we just like in other languages
why don't we just
have functions that take a whole list of
parameters or
like tuple of parameters to be precise in
one go?
why do we do this complicated thing of
taking one argument and then
returning a function that takes the
other
parameter etcetera? Well the reason is
that we can partially apply a function.
For example if we have this function add'
that was defined in a curried way, we can
define a function that
increments a value with 1 by
partially applying
add' to one. If we look at that
type there
add' 1 is a function that takes
an integer
and returns another integer. When we
will talk lists
in a future lecture, we'll see that
there's many functions
that transform lists into other lists
and most of these functions are also defined
in the curried form.
For example the function take here, take 5:
take is defined as a curried function
that takes an integer, returns a function
from list to list,
which means that we can partially
apply
take 5 to yield a function
that takes a list of integers to another
list of integers
which just takes the first five
elements
of the input list. Similarly the function
drop
takes an integer and returns a function
from list to list
and what we see here is that we can now
define drop 5:
we can partially apply drop 5 and it
will return a function
that will take a list, drop the first
five elements
and then return the list. This is super
convenient
and in Haskell it's very lightweight. The
syntax in Haskell
is optimized to have curried functions
and in that respect Haskell is very very
different from
most other languages that are optimized
for functions that take
tuples of arguments. I already mentioned a
couple of times
the way we do the parentheses on
expressions with function parameters.
The arrow associates to the right: if we
have the
type
on the bottom here Int -> Int -> Int -> Int
the parentheses are
associated to the right. Since we don't
like to write parentheses
we can write this thing as Int -> Int -> Int -> Int.
But if we put all the parentheses in there
we get the term here at the bottom, but
this is what we write
because we don't want to write
unnecessary parentheses and as I said
also
when we do function application the
and parentheses associate to the left.
When we partially apply a function
you can write parentheses around that
but we don't have to. When you
write mult x y z
that really means mult x applied
to y applied to z.
Unless you're using explicit
tuples, all functions in Haskell are
normally defined
in curried form. In most languages
all functions are defined in
the uncurried form.
This is part 2 about functions.
There will be
a lot of exercises to drill this idea of
where to put the parentheses
in the function type
and where to put the parentheses in the
expressions,
so this become second nature. This is
something you really have to
keep doing until you don't think
about it anymore.
Alright, please do your exercises
and see you later in the last part
of Chapter 2.